[Música]
então quando eu entrei na neve estou
falando pela web
eu me sentava no cantinho escondidinho
deus não acredita que eu tô aqui nesse
lugar e aí fui me desenvolvendo com o
passar do tempo eu me lembro que meu
minha matéria preferida que eu mais
queria aprender a matéria de
empreendedorismo e empreendedora
aquele sonho nosso vou criar uma empresa
é hoje que vou aprender
aí no dia da primeira aula cheguei lá me
arrumei cheguei cedo sempre tem na
frente queria que o professor me notar
se queria ser a primeira aluna vou sair
daqui
tal ou criar conexões olhei assim
aí ele foi da hora falei agora aprendi
como é que se rica aprender não é como
se uma lida roshan tudo de bom
chega um belo dia que o professor com a
voz bem imponente foi falar dos três
pilares do empreendedorismo e ele falava
na altura então ele com a voz
o primeiro pilar do empreendedorismo
o empreendedor é aquele que tem visão ou
seja a gente aquela pessoa que ver e
enxergar além do horizonte você vê uma
coisa aqui pra você não mudou nada o
empreendedor ou não ele feliz chega a
oportunidade de mudar né de fazer uma
coisa com aquilo e como rr significa
aquela condição ou aquele produto
enfim segundo pilar o emprego daqueles
que têm visão né é aquela pessoa que
corre riscos
esse é o segundo pilar eu sou uma pessoa
corajosa
você hoje pode um homem rico e uma quota
pobre mas empreendedor é isso vá sabendo
que é isso que te espera
e o terceiro é que o empreendedor é a
pessoa que reúne com potências ou seja
mais enxuto e são muita coisa assim
competências que competência fiquei me
perguntando competências de keka
pessoa instrumentalizada naquela pessoa
que sim tem um conhecimento básico de
marketing vendas finanças gestão de
pessoas coisas
todo mundo aqui todo mundo na rua sem
que se conhece tem isso
será que é natural angústia
passou esse fato aí assim foi passado um
livro não é pra gente lê o livro sobre
um empresário de sucesso aquela pessoa
contando a trajetória empresa e tal e aí
a gente tem que fazer um trabalho em
cima disso eu lendo e aí e aí falei meu
deus mas o que é isso
vamos evitar nesse livro não a história
do cara né que um grande empresário mas
encontrava a biografia dele que ele
filho de empresários e estudou nas
melhores escolas da cidade
e aí assim surfava como a z
porque ele é uma pessoa muito pacata e
depois que ele terminar de outra rádio e
lá ele conseguiu as conexões deles de
primeiro emprego está falando a gente
mas aí também
como é que eu nem vejo nesse livro
então pra mim não serve o
empreendedorismo porque a partir de que
o lugar de fala e eu estou me
encontrando aqui
esse não é o meu lugar então assim
fiquei bastante angustiada quando eu li
esse livro então pra mim e quando eu
falo de empreendedorismo eu acho que é
de suma importância que não basta apenas
é as histórias de grandes empresários
tinham preços essas multinacionais mas
também as histórias que demonstrem a
minha visão
sabe aquelas pessoas que têm as mesmas
necessidades e passar pelas mesmas
dificuldades que a minha pra que eu
possa entender nesse processo
poxa mas como é que minha vizinha é que
a cabeleira era manicure mas agora
consegue empregar das pessoas ela está
impactando as vidas isso menos mérito
sabe é uma coisa muito próxima e tudo
que a gente não tá aprendendo sobre isso
porque o fato aqui no brasil
viu nascer negro é você nasceu num lugar
que a discriminação ea desigualdade
social é tamanha que ele coloca sobre as
suas dificuldades normais né que nós
enfrentamos seja de estudo né de
precarização do estudo moradia
saneamento básico
então o afro empreendedorismo ele é
baseado nessas pessoas nas pessoas que
se consideram como negras e que
constroem sua renda através da cultura
negra como fiquei nesse nesse processo
mas não entender eu falei no havaí
quando tava pra terminar o tc falei
agora é minha vez nem vou estudar vou
ver que eu quero escrever fazer artigo
ele descobriu a freqüente de dor smo né
então fui atrás de pesquisar saber o que
era e descobriram um working que era só
para pessoas negras é chamado de ama
coworking lá em salvador que estava
acontecendo e foi nossa incrível quais
são as né
o que eles criam como é esse processo
como é que significa isso essas pessoas
então fui lá fazer pesquisa e tombado
ela fez cheguei meu deus é vadio todo
mundo do coworking gente e agora minha
pesquisa como é que eu vou construir meu
artigo então foi em cima desses dessas
dificuldades que esse artigo foi
construído e que essa crítica sobre como
é ser empreendedor e como é ser negro no
brasil né
já que o empreendedor é uma pessoa que
corre riscos mediante o fato de que a
maioria das famílias no brasil
construída por mulheres negras chefiadas
por mulheres negras mães solteiras e aí
é como é que a gente se identifica nesse
processo de uma pessoa que corre riscos
sabendo que hoje você pode ter o que
comer e amanhã não pode é todo mundo que
tem essa condição
de largar uma renda fixa porque a
maioria dos empresários no brasil são
negros
mas são empreendimentos de baixa
complexidade na maioria são 6 mi
tranquila do individual e empregam
apenas uma pessoa no máximo meio pode
empregar então como a isso como esse
processo porque isso se da cidade dessa
forma né
sendo que através de dados do pnad é
2015 no brasil tinha 54% na é de de
pessoas negras a maioria mas também a
maioria de baixa renda
é a maioria para as áreas mas também a
maioria e meia nequinha
microempreendedor
então como é esse processo como é que a
gente vai conseguir realmente impactar
positivamente e fazer com que esses
empreendedores consigam expandir seus
negócios
então através disso a fan page do
turismo ele busca focar né na expansão
desses projetos a empregar essas pessoas
esses empreendedores entender as
dificuldades reais e desenvolver os
projetos é trazer as comunidades para a
própria perto né não das escolas
administração mas dentro das comunidades
é desenvolver esses empresários enquanto
pessoas não só empreendedorismo é de
negócio mas sim o empreendedorismo de
carreira você se forma e você não sabe
por exemplo o que você vai fazer depois
que você se formou porque a gente não
aprende sobre o negócio sobre como você
fazer networking por exemplo
isso é uma coisa nova pra gente pra hoje
para o jovem no brasil para um jovem
negro principalmente ele está em um
espaço que ele consegue se conectar com
pessoas para poder alavancar nem abrir
seus horizontes suas possibilidades o
que já é uma dificuldade a dificuldade a
gente sair da nossa comunidade que foi
justamente um dos aspectos que levou a
que essas pessoas nesse coworking que
foi pesquisado é fadista em um lugar que
foi por exemplo havia uma situação de
que não coloquem assim a maioria já sabe
né é um espaço colaborativo onde as
pessoas lavam seus materiais a
vão ter um espaço de networking pode
trocar cada um na sua área já foi total
uma informação precisa de um serviço já
tem um outro empresa que o que pode a
lei já ajudar então já cria um
ecossistema favorável e aí anda uma das
coisas que aconteciam na escola eu quero
é o seguinte as pessoas precisavam levar
seus notebooks tablets digital
porém elas iam de ônibus e aí até
dependendo do horário que elas ficavam
lá não tinha condição delas voltarem com
notebook celular de ônibus para lugares
mais distantes
então está falando de necessidades
básicas das pessoas não é que a
segurança é nec é transporte público de
qualidade que não tem como a gente está
falando esse empreendedorismo né
o que é que é você vai lá e faz eu sei
não é estanque saber onde é pra onde é
que a gente está falando pra quem é quem
está falando entender as reais
necessidades dessas pessoas para poder
agir de acordo com as necessidades dela
e ajudar a elas impactar a comunidade é
criar um ecossistema favorável
então quando eu pesquisei e se esse work
eu fui muito feliz de saber que apesar
dos dados serem um pouco pessimistas né
com relação ao nosso desenvolvimento é
que existem pessoas que existem projetos
que estão pensando nisso e é isso que eu
acho que que é o grande valor e isso
tudo é disseminar essa ideia é mostrar a
real necessidade é no dia 23 agora vai
ter também um grande evento não é que é
o vale de que vai ser inaugurado em
salvador
mas aí acho que serve pra bahia todo né
que é uma holding indício social né que
vai ajudar a startup com foco em a fran
perdedores é na população
afro-brasileira então isso é uma
novidade mas também é um grande passo
para que possamos identificar
que há espaço para nós que as nossas
dificuldades podem ser assistidas
envolvidas é através do apoio das outras
pessoas que já estão do outro lado que
já têm conexões que podem fazer essa
ligação é como a minha diz pra mim mas
precisa criar pontes mas precisa saber
como chegar do outro lado às vezes você
vai lá fazer uma graduação e tudo mais
faça faculdade e termina se forma mas
você não sabe que às vezes você fez um
caminho todo tinha um atalho aqui que
você chegava lá né
às vezes a gente se sente tão assim que
ela se sentiu poxa corri tanto podia ter
vindo por aqui que dá no mesmo lugar
então assim é facilitar esse processo né
é eu entendo a frança em 2000 enquanto
isso o protagonismo e desenvolvimento
social e econômico para a população
negra
obrigada
[Aplausos]